frédéric malheureusement des actes
racistes comme ça dans le sport ça ne
date pas d'hier
oui céline et sa touche à peu près tous
les sports certains plus que d'autres
par exemple ont pu remonter jusqu'à jack
robinson qui était l'objet de railleries
de moqueries racistes de la part
d'autres joueurs au baseball
tiger woods souci qui jouait dans un
sport on va le dire assez blanc ait eu
souvent des petits problèmes de
discrimination le hockey avec wayne
simmonds qui jouait pour les flyers de
philadelphie qui a reçu une banane sur
la glace même chose également pour ce
joueur d'origine brésilienne
dani alves et lui ce qu'il a fait dans
le fond mais s'il l'a tourné un peu la
situation à son avantage il a pris la
banane il épluché et il a mangé donc ça
crée un espèce de de mouvement de
sympathie pour sa personne et puis aussi
mais des gens qui ont du pays ça suffit
ce genre d'acte de raciste c'est ça mais
ça n'a pas sa place il faut savoir que
en europe et particulièrement dans le
solaire dans le foot là bas il ya
beaucoup de partisans qui sont
particulièrement agressifs et une
épargne personne par exemple du joueur
vedette de la juventus de turin blaise
matuidi qui était récemment copieusement
hué est traité de tous les noms
même chose également pour kalidou
koulibaly est d'origine sénégalaise qui
joue pour le club de naples lui en fait
il s'est fait huer et on l'a fait sortir
sous des crises imitation de singe alors
évidemment ce qui est inquiétant aussi
c'est que il ya vraiment recrudescente
ce genre d'actes dont qui les insultent
des attaques des cris racistes des
crachats des lancers d'objets et tout ça
même ça se transforme ça ce transfert on
va dire sur les réseaux sociaux donc ça
prend vraiment une ampleur chic bordeaux
réapprend importante et que font les
fédérations les associations sportives
notamment en europe où ça se produit
beaucoup exactement mais parlons du
soccer il ya l'uefa dont qui est
l'association qui regroupe tous les
clubs de poker d'europe qui s'est
associé avec football contre le racisme
en europe pour essayer de sensibiliser
davantage les clubs à ce genre de
problème et c'est vraiment s'est laissée
au bon vouloir de ces clubs là donc il y
en a qui font des efforts d'autres pas
du tout l'italie avec sa fédération de
football vient récemment de prendre de
nouvelles mesures par exemple dès qu'il
y à un premier signalement de cris
racistes dans la foulée bien ce qu'on
fait on l'a tous les joueurs de se
rendre au milieu du terrain d'arrêter de
jouer et si jamais il ya d'autres
incidents racistes qui sont rapportés
pendant la même partie à ce moment là eh
bien on arrête le jeu
et les joueurs s'en vont dans le
vestiaire en france là on a pris
beaucoup de mesures et des amendes
contre ses partisans et ne des sanctions
judiciaires interdiction de stade pour
une même interdiction de s'abonner pour
des saisons complètes de soccer et enfin
pour aussi sensibiliser les clubs ce
qu'on fait lorsqu'il ne n'arrive pas à
tempérer les ardeurs de leurs partisans
qu'est ce qui se passait bien c'est un
match comme ça et il ya personne dans
les gradins
donc ça veut dire que les clubs
finalement ne font pas d'argent ces
soirs là il n'y a pas de rentrées
financières donc c'est vraiment pour les
forcer à balayer devant leurs portes
pour éviter que ce genre de commentaires
racistes toujours vraiment les joueurs
d'un peu partout dans le monde
intéressant merci fermé vous en prie